Let's talk to, why don't we go to the seven
one three area code?
Who's calling today from seven one three.
Hi David.
This is Gabe.
I'm from Houston, Texas.
Hey Gabe, what's going on?
So I saw that poll that came out.
I'm sure you saw it too regarding AOC and
Omar, how they're pulling at, I think it's
22% POC and maybe 9% for Elano Omar.
Well, here's the thing.
There's two polls that came out.
One of them is only polling like white people
with under two years of college education
or something like that.
That one is not surprisingly drastically understating
the overall support for those members of Congress.
There's another poll, which the numbers still
aren't amazing, but they're way better than
the ones Trump cited.
So, which of the two Poles were you talking
about?
I think I was talking about the former poll,
the one that uh, has the lower results because
I've been hearing a lot of talk from conservatives
that this will be used to kind of sideline
or force AOC and the squad to be silent in
their opposition to the establishment because
they could potentially be harmful to, uh,
the Democratic nominee.
Do you see that as a potential kind of strategy
used by conservatives or should, should these
poll numbers be kind of taken with a grain
of salt?
Well, listen, you have to understand any poll,
the country is more than white people with
under two years of college.
So first of all, any poll that tells you someone
is popular or unpopular merely by polling
white people under two with under two years
of college education is not an accurate poll.
So that would be a really stupid poll to use
to justify those for members of Congress being
a risk to the Democratic Party.
What most importantly we have to think about
is they don't have to even win over Democrats
in the entire country in order to keep getting
reelected.
All that matters is their district, a lot
of those districts.
So certainly with a [inaudible] district and
maybe also with Alano Mars district, those
are blue districts.
And so the real challenge to those members
of Congress is more likely to come oh, from
within the Democratic Party rather than from
a Republican.
Um, and if you look at, I believe it's a YouGov
poll, they still don't have the best favor
ability ratings, but they are slightly better
than the Democratic Party in total, which
means they're probably on track for reelection
in their, in their respective districts.
So I just don't see the math justifying this
concern that the right says the democrats
should have about the four of them.
They seem to be popular enough to get reelected
in their own districts.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking of course.
Because obviously you look at people like
Mitch is one of the most wear senators out
there, but it's not like he's going to be
potentially harmful to the Republican Party
and he has no trouble about getting reelected.
Well, maybe he will in 2020.
I know there's some opposition, but yeah,
obviously if you just take those numbers over
to the Republicans, the math, Justin.
Yeah.
Justify that.
And I think the important thing to understand
is even though Mitch McConnell's favor ability
in his state is not that high, it doesn't
mean that Republican voters in Kentucky are
going to vote for a democrat.
They might prefer a different Republican,
but in the end they'll still vote for Mitch
McConnell.
And the opposite is true in a lot of these
democratic districts as well.
So I think that it's, it's really kind of
a, a very empty attack, at least at this point
in time.
Nope.
Okay.
Well glad for, glad to hear from you on that.
It's been a ever since I've, okay.
And I think why me and my liberal friends
had been kind of worried about this, so, so
glad to hear, uh, an objective, uh, take on
those poll numbers.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you.
Appreciate the call.